Start the drill by taking position on your knees,
one hand on the ground
with your opposite off hand up in front of you
similar to your 3 point stance.
Sit back on your heels,
extend explosively
forward and outward by thrusting your hips
and shooting your hands to full extension.
Always keep your eyes up through full extension.
Land safely with your hands and chest
in a push up position.
Recover back to your hand and knees
to repeat for multiple reps.
Rep the drill in both a right and left handed stance.
This drill helps create explosion out of your stance
using power created in your hips
as you strike your opponent with violent hand use.